I'm in the Office of Dr. LJ Drakovic, who examines dead bodies for the police in Pontiac, Michigan. And he's running through this carousel of slides, all of them murder victims. There are closeups of body parts.
我正在密歇根州庞蒂亚克的LJ·德拉科维奇博士的办公室里，他为当地警方负责尸检。他正在查看一系列幻灯片，全都是谋杀案的受害者，上面还有身体部位的特写。
To say, as you just flip through these things, this is the grisliest slide show I've ever seen. It's just like every slide is some...
当你翻看这些东西时，只能说这是我见过最惨不忍睹的幻灯片了。每一张幻灯片似乎都是……
--is another story, yes. Every crime scene is a story of its own, is a novel. And it opens up in every direction.
——是另一个故事，没错。每一个犯罪现场本身就是一个故事，一本小说。它向各个方向展开。
To illustrate, he tells me this story. When he worked for the Wayne County coroner's office back in Detroit, there was a young woman. This story, by the way, might not be suitable for younger children.
为了说明这一点，他给我讲了这个故事。当他还在底特律的韦恩县验尸官办公室工作时，曾有一位年轻女性的案件。顺便说一下，这个故事可能不适合年幼的孩子。
Anyway, there's this young woman who apparently killed herself by taking her boyfriend's gun, putting it in her mouth and firing. The police, the other medical examiners, everybody thought it was a suicide. But something about the case bothered Dr. Drakovic. The woman didn't have a history of depression. There was no note.
总之，有一位年轻女性显然是用她男友的枪，塞进嘴里开枪自杀了。警方、其他验尸官，所有人都认为这是一起自杀。但德拉科维奇博士觉得案子有些不对劲。这位女性没有抑郁症病史，也没有留下遗书。
My colleagues teased me as being paranoid and seeing things where they were not. I did the examination. I did the examination of the oral cavity. And in this particular case, the tongue showed two holes.
同事们嘲笑我多疑，无中生有。我进行了检查，我对口腔进行了检查。在这个特殊的案例中，舌头上出现了两个孔。
This is very strange, Dr. Drakovic explained, because usually-- again, this gets a little explicit-- usually, when people shoot themselves in the mouth, they kind of point the gun upward, toward the brain. Their tongue does not get injured at all. But here, the tongue must have been all bunched up, pushing hard against the muzzle of the gun.
德拉科维奇博士解释说，这非常奇怪，因为通常——再说一次，这可能会有点令人不适——通常当人们对着嘴开枪时，他们会把枪口向上对着大脑，舌头根本不会受伤。但在这里，舌头一定是蜷缩在一起，用力顶着枪口。
Now, who in this world, trying to end life, will inflict additional pain and discomfort by shoving the muzzle of the gun against the tongue? Unless it's another person. In my assessment of this, this was a homicide.
那么，在这个世界上，有谁在试图结束生命时，会通过将枪口顶在舌头上，来增加自己的痛苦和不适呢？除非是另有他人。根据我的评估，这是一起他杀。
So I told the detectives that that was my finding. They went back to interview the boyfriend. And they said, we know that you shot her. He said, no, I didn't. They said, yes, we know. The doctor told us. He said, what doctor? They says, the doctor that did the autopsy. He said, what autopsy? I called the coroner's office two weeks ago, and they told me they never did autopsies on suicides.
于是我告诉侦探那是我的发现。他们回去审问那个男友。他们说：“我们知道是你杀了她。”他说：“不，不是我。”他们说：“是的，我们知道，医生告诉我们的。”他说：“哪个医生？”他们说：“做尸检的那个医生。”他说：“什么尸检？我两周前给验尸官办公室打过电话，他们告诉我他们从不对自杀者进行尸检。”
Of course, why call the coroner's office to ask that question if you're not planning on killing anybody? It did not take very long for the police to get a confession out of this guy. As Dr. Drakovic says, every crime scene is a novel.
当然，如果你没打算杀人，为什么还要给验尸官办公室打那个电话呢？没过多久，警方就让这家伙招供了。正如德拉科维奇博士所说，每一个犯罪现场都是一本小说。
Today in our radio program, crime scenes and the stories behind them. For WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讨论犯罪现场以及它们背后的故事。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our show today, How Do We Know? A forensic criminologist explains exactly what it is that we can learn from evidence at a crime scene.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“我们是如何知道的？”一位法医犯罪学家解释了我们到底能从犯罪现场的证据中学到什么。
Act Two, Grime Scene. Nancy Updike reports on how watching the movie Pulp Fiction led one man to a life coming in after the police and the investigators are done.
第二幕，“犯罪现场清洁工”。南希·厄普代克报道了观看电影《低俗小说》是如何让一名男子走上了一条在警察和调查员结束后进行后续清理工作的道路。
Act Three-- in the second half of our show, I have to say, everything gets a little less grisly. Act Three, A Criminal Returns to the Scene of the Crime, a story of a thief who returns to the neighborhood where he robbed and conned people, to coach little league.
第三幕——在节目的后半部分，我得说，一切都变得不那么恐怖了。第三幕，“罪犯重返犯罪现场”，讲述了一个小偷回到他曾抢劫和欺诈过的社区，去担任少棒联盟教练的故事。
Act Four, What Police Cannot Do. We have this completely beautiful, haunting story by Aimee Bender about a little boy who can find any lost object, any stolen object, from any crime scene. Stay with us.
第四幕，“警察做不到的事”。我们有艾米·本德创作的一篇非常优美、令人难以忘怀的故事，讲述了一个小男孩，他能从任何犯罪现场找到丢失的或被盗的物品。请继续收听。
Act One, How Do We Know? Well, we thought we would start this hour with a quick primer on some of the kinds of evidence that investigators find at crime scenes and what it tells them. Enrico Togneri is a former forensic criminologist in Nevada. He says there's a lot of information contained in something as simple as the shape of a blood stain. He talks about high-velocity blood stains and low-velocity blood stains.
第一幕，“我们是如何知道的？”我们想先从一些调查员在犯罪现场发现的证据类型以及这些证据能告诉他们什么开始。恩里科·托格内里是内华达州的前法医犯罪学家。他说，像血迹形状这样简单的东西里包含着大量信息。他谈到了高速血迹和低速血迹。
Well, the blood spatter, when you have a low velocity, something like an arterial cut, where somebody is cut in the artery and it's actually spurting out of the body, you get fairly large stains because you have quite a bit of blood coming off at the fairly low velocity.
嗯，血迹喷溅，当你处于低速时，比如动脉切口，某人的动脉被割破，血液实际上是从体内喷出来的，你会得到相当大的血迹，因为你有相当多的血液以相当低的速度飞出。
Higher velocity, like somebody being hit with a baseball bat, you're going to get a teardrop shape. The lower the angle, the more the teardrop. If it's straight on, it's going to be a nice round droplet.
如果是高速，比如被人用棒球棍击中，你会得到泪滴状的痕迹。角度越低，泪滴形状越明显。如果是正面击中，就会是一个漂亮的圆形小液滴。
And then if you have high velocity, which is a gunshot, you almost get a mist because of the impact of the gunshot causing an explosion of the blood. So you get a very fine mist.
如果你有高速，也就是枪伤，因为枪击的冲击力导致血液爆炸，你几乎会得到一种雾状物。所以你会得到非常细微的血雾。
And I understand that from the shape of the droplets, you can tell where the person was standing?
我理解通过小液滴的形状，你可以判断出那个人当时站在哪里？
Yeah, it's basic trigonometry. What you do is you take the width of the bloodstain and the length of the bloodstain, and you find the angle. And from the angle, you can actually string it. You can actually run a string back away from the wall of the angle you've determined it to have impacted at. And if you do this from several little droplets, you eventually come to a point where they bunch up. And that would be where the blood impact actually originated.
是的，这是基本的三角学。你所要做的就是测量血迹的宽度和长度，然后算出角度。通过角度，你实际上可以进行连线。你实际上可以沿着你测定的撞击角度，从墙壁向后拉一根线。如果你从几个小液滴这样做，你最终会到达它们汇聚的一点。那就是血液撞击实际发生的源头。
There was a case where an individual had said that he got into a fight with his roommate, and the fight occurred as they were standing up. And he hit the guy, and the guy finally dropped dead.
有一个案例，一个人说他和室友打架，打架发生在他们站着的时候。他打了那个人，那个人最终倒地身亡。
But in reality, when we constructed the blood spatter by stringing it, we could show that all came from a fairly low place on the floor, from a few inches up from the floor. And you could show that most of the impacts happened when the individual was already down, so therefore taking away the self-defense issue.
但实际上，当我们通过连线还原血迹喷溅情况时，我们可以证明所有血液都来自地板上相当低的位置，离地面只有几英寸。你可以证明大多数撞击发生在受害者已经倒下的时候，因此排除了自卫的说法。
In other words, he was kicking him while he was literally on the ground.
换句话说，当他在地上的时候，他在踢他。
That's correct.
没错。
Could I just get you to list briefly all the things that you can learn from all the types of evidence that are there on a scene?
你能简要列出你能从现场所有类型的证据中学到的东西吗？
Yeah, there's certain routine things that you would look for. And let's say you get into a scene where there's still some food on the table. You want to see if it's still warm. You want to see what the food is. You want to see where the placing of the utensils might be. That might give you a clue whether it's a right-handed or left-handed person that was last there.
是的，你会寻找一些常规的东西。假设你进入一个现场，桌子上还有些食物。你想看看它是否还是温的。你想看看是什么食物。你想看看餐具摆放的位置。这可能会给你线索，判断最后在那里的人是惯用右手还是左手。
You want to actually observe everything that's there as far as, do you see any blood, any hair, any fibers? If the police officer who was there at the crime scene, who got there first, or even one of the witnesses who got there first, if you can get them to describe, was there any unique smells? A smell could be important-- a cigar smoke. You never know.
你想要观察那里的一切，比如，你看到血迹、毛发或纤维吗？如果第一个到达犯罪现场的警官，或者甚至第一个到达的证人，如果你能让他们描述一下，是否有任何独特的气味？气味可能很重要——比如雪茄烟味。你永远不知道。
If you can remember, can you think of a case where an utterly ordinary object ended up being the piece of evidence that clinched it?
如果记得的话，你能想出一个完全普通的物体最终成为决定性证据的案例吗？
Well, as a matter of fact, there was a burglary with a piece of cheese that had a tooth mark in it. And we were able to match the bite mark to the individual that did the burglary.
事实上，曾有一起盗窃案，现场有一块带着牙印的奶酪。我们能够将咬痕与实施盗窃的那个人进行匹配。
What?
什么？
Just a piece of cheese left in the refrigerator. The individual decided to help himself to some food. And he took a bite out of a piece of cheese. And he had a unique enough bite mark that we were able to identify it.
只是留在冰箱里的一块奶酪。那个人决定自取食物。他在奶酪上咬了一口。他的咬痕非常有特点，我们得以确认了他的身份。
When the police are done with a crime scene, who actually cleans up the crime scene?
当警察完成犯罪现场调查后，到底是谁来清理现场？
Usually the person who owns the property. We would mark it as a possible biohazard, and then the individual would hire whoever he wanted to hire to have it cleaned up.
通常是房产所有人。我们会将其标记为可能的生物危害，然后房主会雇佣他想雇佣的人来清理。
Other drivers stare at Neal Smither's truck and sometimes take pictures. On the sides and back of it, in big red letters, is the company name-- "Crime Scene Cleaners, specializing in homicides, suicides, and accidental deaths."
其他司机盯着尼尔·史密瑟的卡车看，有时还会拍照。在卡车侧面和后面，用醒目的大红字写着公司名称——“犯罪现场清洁工，专门处理谋杀、自杀和意外死亡。”
Well, this is Nancy Updike, and this is act two of our show-- Act Two, Grime Scene. Nancy went to the San Francisco Bay area to see Neal Smither, who cleans up crime scenes for a living. A quick warning-- some of this might not be suitable for younger listeners, the squeamish, and wussies.
我是南希·厄普代克，这是我们节目的第二幕——第二幕，“犯罪现场清洁工”。南希去了旧金山湾区拜访尼尔·史密瑟，他以清理犯罪现场为生。温馨提示——部分内容可能不适合年幼的听众、胆小者或软弱的人。
After spending two days with Neal Smither, I was this close to signing up to open his Los Angeles franchise. I'm not joking. Neal spends all day, every day, speeding around in a huge white pickup truck with a cell phone glued to his ear, making sure his company gets to dispose of every drop of blood within driving distance of Orinda, California, and his franchises in Utah, Kansas, Texas, Las Vegas, and Alabama.
在和尼尔·史密瑟相处两天后，我差点就报名去开他的洛杉矶分部了。我没开玩笑。尼尔整天都在开着一辆巨大的白色皮卡车飞驰，手机粘在耳朵上，确保他的公司能处理奥林达周边地区以及他在犹他州、堪萨斯州、德克萨斯州、拉斯维加斯和阿拉巴马州的分部所覆盖的每一滴血。
Mostly, he doesn't leave the truck. He's had this one for about a year, and it's got 90,000 miles on it. Neal is absolutely blunt about his job, to the point of crassness.
大部分时间他都不下车。他这辆车开了大约一年，已经跑了9万英里。尼尔对他的工作非常直率，甚至有些粗鲁。
I did a job one time. An old guy dropped dead, decomposed on his kitchen floor. So when we got there, we had about a 10-by-5-foot square pool of just gore-- no power in the house, so it's dark. It's very quiet. I'm in there with a respirator because it was just humming. It smelled.
我有一次做过一个活儿。一个老人猝死了，在厨房地板上腐烂了。所以当我们到达时，我们看到了一片10乘5英尺的血浆池——屋里没有电，所以很暗。非常安静。我戴着呼吸器进去，因为那里嗡嗡作响。味道很难闻。
I'm hearing this noise, and I shouldn't be hearing the noise. There's no power in this house, nothing. I got a flashlight. I'm hearing this funky noise, man. What the [BLEEP] is that?
我听到一种声音，我不应该听到那种声音。这房子没电，什么都没有。我带着手电筒。我听到一种古怪的声音，伙计。那是什么鬼东西？
So I get closer to the gore with my light, and it's just a bowling ball-size thing of maggots, and they're writhing around in the blood and the gore. And it sounds like when you knead hamburger.
于是我带着灯光靠近那滩血肉，那是一个保龄球大小的蛆团，它们在血液和烂肉里蠕动。听起来就像你在揉捏汉堡肉一样。
The maggots were making a sound that you could hear?
蛆虫发出的声音你能听见？
There were so many of them, just so many of them writhing around in this pool of gore that yeah, you could hear them.
它们太多了，有那么多在血泊中蠕动，是的，你可以听到它们的声音。
The only time he speaks gently about what he does is on sales calls.
他唯一温和地谈论他工作的时候是在推销电话中。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃响]
Hi there, this is Neal. May I help you? Yes, sir. Yes, sir. All righty.
你好，我是尼尔。有什么能帮您的吗？是的，先生。好的，先生。明白了。
That's all you need to tell me. Let me kind of walk you through how we work. We'd have a crew to you within the hour. They'd write you up a free estimate. If you like the estimate, they'd rock and roll on that job right then and there. Our services are all-inclusive.
那只需要告诉我就行了。让我带您了解一下我们的工作流程。我们会在一小时内派人过去。他们会给您写一份免费评估报告。如果您喜欢这个评估，他们会立即开始工作。我们的服务是全包的。
By the way, have you noticed Neal's southern accent? He made it up. He borrowed it from his Arkansas grandparents so he could play Steel Magnolia during business negotiations. He grew up in Santa Cruz. He has no problem admitting the accent is cultivated.
顺便问一下，你注意到尼尔的南方口音了吗？那是他编出来的。他借用了他阿肯色州祖父母的口音，这样他在商务谈判时就能扮演“钢木兰”的角色。他在圣克鲁斯长大。他毫不避讳地承认这种口音是刻意培养的。
Something about a Southern voice that just kind of opens up a trusting vein, you know? Which is great. I mean, that's what I want.
南方口音有一种能打开信任之门的感觉，你知道吗？这太棒了。我的意思是，这就是我想要的。
Neal has that tightly-wound energy like Jim Carrey. He's 5'5" with short brown hair under a baseball cap and sunglasses. He smokes Kools, does not stop for lunch, and drives way too fast. The directness, the crassness, is all deliberate. It's his marketing strategy.
尼尔有一种像吉姆·凯瑞那样的紧绷感。他身高5英尺5英寸，戴着棒球帽和太阳镜，遮住了一头棕色的短发。他抽Kool牌香烟，不吃午饭，开车开得太快。这种直接和粗鲁都是故意的。这是他的营销策略。
Gore sells. Look at the truck. We're pretty up front. I hope I don't offend too many people. I just try to be honest with them. We're dealing with death. How do you sugarcoat death? You can't.
血腥味能卖钱。看看那辆卡车。我们很坦率。我希望我不会冒犯太多人。我只是试着对他们诚实。我们处理的是死亡。你如何美化死亡？你做不到。
Neal describes for me the outline left on a leather couch by a body that has decomposed into it over the course of 60 days. And I want to stop here and acknowledge that this is gross. It is. It's gross. But it's interesting. And to me, it's much more interesting than it is gross. I mean, think of it-- a melted person.
尼尔向我描述了一个死者在真皮沙发上留下的轮廓，死者在沙发上腐烂了60天。我想停在这里承认一下，这很恶心。是的，确实恶心。但它很有趣。对我来说，它比恶心更有趣。我的意思是，想想看——一个融化的人。
Four years ago, Neal had never seen a dead body. He was a laid-off mortgage broker, for God's sake. Then he saw Pulp Fiction. Remember that scene where John Travolta blows the guy's head off in the back of the car by mistake, and they have to call in Mr. Wolf to fix everything?
四年前，尼尔从没见过死人。看在上帝份上，他曾是一名被裁员的抵押贷款经纪人。然后他看了《低俗小说》。记得那一幕吗？约翰·特拉沃尔塔失手把那个人的头炸飞在车后座，他们必须叫“狼先生”来处理所有事情。
Good. I need you two folks to do is take these cleaning products and clean the inside of the car. You need to go in the back seat. Scoop up all those little pieces of brain and skull. Get it out of there.
好。你们两个需要做的是拿着这些清洁产品清理车厢内部。你们得进后座，把那些脑浆和头盖骨碎片全部铲起来。清理干净。
Neal is possibly the only person in America who saw that scene and thought, wow, I want that job. And it turns out it is a real job. If someone dies in your house, it's up to you to get it clean.
尼尔可能是美国唯一一个看了那一幕后心想“哇，我想要那份工作”的人。事实证明，这确实是一份真正的工作。如果有人死在你的房子里，清理干净就得靠你了。
But doing it yourself, even if you wanted to, raises all sorts of problems. Are you complying with the state and federal laws governing the disposal of bodies and bodily fluids? Do you have the proper permits and liability coverage? No, you don't. So you call Neal.
但即使你想自己动手，也会带来各种问题。你遵守有关处理尸体和体液的州和联邦法律吗？你有适当的许可证和责任保险吗？不，你没有。所以你要给尼尔打电话。
Here's how his job breaks down. Murders are the least of his business. Most of the cleanups are either decomps-- bodies that have sat for a while and started to decompose--
他的工作内容如下：谋杀案占他业务的最少部分。大部分清理工作要么是腐烂尸体——放置了一段时间并开始腐烂的尸体——
I did a decomp on the very end unit upstairs there. It was bad.
我在那边的楼上单元做了个腐烂尸体清理。情况很糟。
How long it had been going?
已经放了多久了？
He sat for a good long while. He was all humming-- maggots everywhere. It was a typical decomp.
他放了相当长的一段时间。到处都在嗡嗡作响——满地都是蛆。这是一起典型的腐烂尸体案。
--or suicides. Suicides and attempted suicides are a surprisingly big part of his job. The rest of Neal's business consists of meth labs and kitty houses. Kitty houses are those places, usually full of old newspapers and other garbage, that have dozens of cats everywhere, eating and peeing and crapping.
——要么是自杀。自杀和自杀未遂在他工作中占很大比例。尼尔剩下的业务包括制毒实验室和猫舍。猫舍就是那些地方，通常塞满了旧报纸和其他垃圾，到处都是几十只猫，吃喝拉撒都在里面。
Meth labs are usually hotel accounts. Neal has a few national chains on contract. Hotel rooms get used all the time to cook methamphetamine, Neal says. He does a lot of business with hotels. He claims, hyperbolically, that there's no hotel in the country that hasn't had a murder or suicide in one of its rooms.
制毒实验室通常是酒店的生意。尼尔有一些连锁酒店的合同。尼尔说，酒店房间经常被用来制作甲基苯丙胺。他与酒店有很多业务往来。他夸张地说，全国没有一家酒店没有发生过谋杀或自杀事件。
The second day I spend with Neal, he gets called out to a jail to clean up after a woman who tried to kill herself in the bathroom off the prisoners' waiting room. I'm not allowed to record anything. I have to just watch.
我和尼尔一起度过的第二天，他被叫到一个监狱，清理一名试图在囚犯候见室旁边的浴室里自杀的妇女的现场。我不被允许记录任何东西。我只能看。
I hold open the bathroom door with my foot while Neal sets up his stuff. Next to the sink are several thick, dark red drops of blood. And there are a few streaks of blood on the wall. Inside the sink is more blood. It isn't a lot, maybe 1/3 of a cup overall. But clearly, she did some damage.
我用脚顶着浴室的门，尼尔在里面布置他的东西。水槽旁边有几滴深红色的厚重血迹。墙上还有几道血迹。水槽里有更多的血。量不多，总共大概三分之一杯。但很明显，她造成了一些伤害。
Then, while Neal is getting into his protective suit, a woman in the waiting room behind us-- a tweaker, Neal confided to me later, meaning a meth user-- reads the back of Neal's shirt out loud. "Crime scene cleaners," she says. "You cleaned my mother's house."
然后，当尼尔穿上防护服时，我们身后的候见室里有一个女人——尼尔后来私下告诉我她是个“瘾君子”，意思是冰毒使用者——大声读出了尼尔衬衫背后的字。“犯罪现场清洁工，”她说。“你们清理过我妈妈的房子。”
Neal turns around. "Yeah? Which one was that?"
尼尔转过身。“是吗？哪一个是？”
Without any emotion, the woman says her mother and cousin were murdered by her mother's boyfriend a while ago. "You guys cleaned the house," she repeats.
那个女人毫无表情地说，她妈妈和表亲前段时间被她妈妈的男友谋杀了。“你们清理过那房子，”她重复道。
"Oh, yeah, I remember that one. That was on the news," Neal says.
“哦，是的，我记得那个案子。新闻上报道过，”尼尔说。
The woman nods and doesn't say anything. So Neal goes back to cleaning. He whips through it in about 10 minutes, like it's spilt milk. In fact, it's exactly like cleaning up a mess at home, except with industrial-strength cleansers and equipment. He snaps on some rubber gloves, sprays the whole area with a special enzyme to neutralize the blood and kill any bacteria or viruses, scrubs any tough spots with a little brush, and then wipes everything clean with heavy-duty paper towels. It isn't hard, just depressing.
那个女人点了点头，什么也没说。于是尼尔回去继续清理。他像清理打翻的牛奶一样在10分钟内完成了工作。事实上，这就像在家里清理烂摊子一样，只是用了工业强度的清洁剂和设备。他戴上橡胶手套，用特殊的酶喷洒整个区域以中和血液并杀灭细菌或病毒，用小刷子刷洗任何顽固点，然后用重型纸巾擦拭干净。这并不难，只是让人压抑。
Bottom line, I'm a businessman. I'm an entrepreneur. I want to make money and build my company.
归根结底，我是个商人。我是个创业者。我想赚钱并建立我的公司。
Were you like this as a kid?
你小时候也是这样吗？
Well, I was the kid in school who would buy boxes of Blow Pops and bring them to school and sell them at lunch. I was the kid at school who ran a lunch ticket scam.
嗯，我在学校是个会买几箱泡泡糖带到学校，在午餐时卖掉的孩子。我还是在学校搞午餐券骗局的孩子。
What was the lunch ticket scam?
什么是午餐券骗局？
I had a girlfriend in the office, the head office in high school. And she'd kick me down with lunch tickets for a discounted price, and then I'd sell them for an increased price. But it was still lower than what the Mexican kids or whoever could buy them from the school. So I figure I beat the school by $0.20 a ticket.
我在高中校办有个女朋友。她会以折扣价给我午餐券，然后我以更高的价格卖掉。但它仍然比墨西哥孩子或其他什么人从学校买的便宜。所以我算了一下，我每张票赚了0.20美元。
[BLEEP], I bankrolled my whole high school career on Blow Pops and lunch tickets. It was a beautiful thing. I always had money. And I didn't break any laws, didn't sling dope, none of that [BLEEP]. Bought my own car, and I bankrolled it with Blow Pops and lunch tickets.
[脏话]，我的整个高中生涯都是靠泡泡糖和午餐券撑起来的。这真是一件美妙的事。我一直有钱。我没触犯任何法律，没干过什么毒品交易，没干那些[脏话]。我买了自己的车，全靠泡泡糖和午餐券资金支持。
Neal's plan is to retire in seven years at 40 and be rich. But in the meantime, the job is changing him. Seeing so many crime scenes, seeing the way so many people die, he's also seen how they live-- in houses filled with old newspapers, dirty dishes, and too many cats, never cleaning the bathroom.
尼尔的计划是在七年后40岁时退休并变富有。但在此期间，这份工作正在改变他。看到如此多的犯罪现场，看到那么多人死亡的方式，他也看到了他们是如何生活的——在装满旧报纸、脏碗碟和太多猫的房子里，从不打扫浴室。
I think more than anything now, most people are just dirty mother-[BLEEP]. We live like animals, man. You have no idea.
我觉得现在最重要的是，大多数人简直就是肮脏的[脏话]。我们像动物一样生活，伙计。你根本不知道。
I'm a clean freak. My place is spotless. So when I got into this, I was shocked by the way people live. It's amazing.
我是个清洁狂。我的住处一尘不染。所以当我进入这个行业时，我对人们的生活方式感到震惊。太惊人了。
I went into a bathroom yesterday at a car wash. A guy in there doing his business, and I walk into the thing, and this guy had thrown his garbage on the floor and didn't flush the toilet-- just no common courtesy at all.
昨天我去了一个洗车场的浴室。一个家伙在里面办事情，我走进那个地方，这家伙把垃圾扔在地上，还没冲马桶——简直一点基本的礼貌都没有。
And he was in a tie and a clean-cut nice looking guy. Didn't your mom teach you anything, you 40-year-old dirt bag? Are you just a dirt bag? That's dirt bag, straight up. That is a dirt bag.
而且他打着领带，看起来是个干干净净的好人。你妈妈没教过你什么吗，你这个40岁的脏东西？你就是个脏东西吗？那就是个脏东西，直白地说。那就是个脏东西。
Did you think people were this big dirt bags before this job?
在做这份工作之前，你以为人们是这种大脏东西吗？
No, I had no idea. I had no idea. I thought everyone was normal. Believe me, the normal is the dirt bag in this. [BLEEP].
不，我根本不知道。我不知道。我以为每个人都很正常。相信我，在这一点上，正常人才是脏东西。[脏话]。
But now you see more dirt baggery everywhere?
但现在你随处可见这种肮脏行为？
Oh, it's 80/20 dirt bag. You bet. I swear to God.
哦，80%都是脏东西。你赌吧。我对上帝发誓。
So now, I'll go home and take a hot shower. Then I'll convert to a bathtub, read my book, and not think about dirt bags, wait for my girl to get home, wait for death. Death or my girl, I love them both.
所以现在，我会回家洗个热水澡。然后我会换到浴缸里，看我的书，不去想那些脏东西，等我的女朋友回家，等死亡。死亡或我的女朋友，我都爱。
Neal's thought a lot about his own death in the last few years, not surprisingly. He says he wants to die slowly, so he can say goodbye to everyone. He doesn't want to be found by a company like his and cleaned up, with his family off somewhere wondering what happened.
不出所料，尼尔在过去几年里对自己死亡的想法考虑了很多。他说他想慢慢死，这样他可以和每个人告别。他不想被像他这样的公司发现并清理，而他的家人却在别处想发生了什么事。
He doesn't even care if it's a painful death, he says, as long as it's slow. Cancer would be fine, he says. He'd take cancer. When was the last time you heard someone say that?
他说他甚至不在乎死得痛不痛苦，只要是慢慢地就行。他说癌症也没关系。他愿意接受癌症。你上次听到有人这么说是什么时候？
Nancy Updike is the biggest producer for our program. We heard about Neal Smither from the book Gig, which is a kind of unofficial sequel/tribute to Studs Terkel's classic book about Americans and their jobs, Working.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的首席制片人。我们从《Gig》这本书中听说了尼尔·史密瑟，这本书算是斯塔兹·特克尔关于美国人及其职业的经典书籍《工作》的非官方续集/致敬之作。
[MUSIC - JAMES BROWN, "PAPA DON'T TAKE NO MESS, PT. 1"]
[音乐 - 詹姆斯·布朗，“爸爸不吃这一套，第一部分”]
(SINGING) Yeah, Papa don't take no mess. Papa don't take no mess. Papa is the man who can understand how a man has to do whatever he can. Hit me.
(演唱) 是的，爸爸不吃这一套。爸爸不吃这一套。爸爸是个明白人，明白男人为了生活必须竭尽所能。来吧。
Coming up, no more grossness, promise. And what's it mean when you get out of prison, kick a drug habit, return to the scene of your crimes, and little kids make fun of you? Kindergarten con in a minute by Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，不再有恶心的东西，我保证。当你出狱后，戒掉毒瘾，回到犯罪现场，小孩子们嘲笑你，这意味着什么？幼儿园骗局，国际公共广播电台节目继续时马上为你带来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- crime scenes and the stories they tell. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Return to the Scene of the Crime.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给你各种各样的故事。今天的节目——犯罪现场以及它们诉说的故事。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“重返犯罪现场”。
There's a truism in detective fiction that a criminal always returns to the scene of the crime. But it turns out, in real life, that actually is not very common, except maybe among arsonists. Arsonists like to see the fires they've set, apparently, and some of them are caught when police look at pictures taken of the crowd at various fires.
侦探小说里有一句老话，罪犯总是重返犯罪现场。但事实证明，在现实生活中，这种情况其实并不常见，除了纵火犯。显然，纵火犯喜欢看到他们纵的火，有些人就是在警察观察在各类火灾现场人群的照片时被抓获的。
And then-- maybe it's very rare, maybe not. Nobody really tracks this kind of thing. There are the people who circle back to the scene of their crimes to undo, to erase something, or at least to promise it'll never happen again. Katie Davis discovered that one of her own neighbors in Washington, DC, an old friend, was trying to do just that.
然后——也许这非常罕见，也许不是。没人真的追踪这类事情。有些人回到犯罪现场是为了补救、消除某些东西，或者至少承诺永远不再发生。凯蒂·戴维斯发现，她在华盛顿特区的一位邻居，一位老朋友，正试图这样做。
Bobby comes up my street one afternoon in March. I haven't seen him in a few months. And he's kind of gliding along, smoking a Marlboro. That's the way he's carried himself since sixth grade, when I first met him-- one of the bad boys from over on Calvert Street.
三月的一个下午，鲍比沿着我的街道走上来。我已经几个月没见到他了。他正在滑行，抽着万宝路。这是他从七年级我第一次见他起就有的样子——来自卡尔弗街的坏小子之一。
Bobby tells me he's going to coach a Little League team with some neighborhood kids. "Great," I say from up on my porch. Inside, I'm thinking, "Who's he kidding? He's rail-thin. He's sweating. It looks like he's been using all winter."
鲍比告诉我，他要去和一个邻居的孩子一起指导少棒联盟队。“太棒了，”我在门廊上说。我心里想，“他跟谁开玩笑呢？他瘦骨嶙峋的。他在冒汗。看起来他整个冬天都在吸毒。”
Bobby flicks his burning cigarette into the street and watches me, waiting for more reaction. This is the same Bobby I loved and tried to save for a whole year, Bobby who stole $60 from my house to buy heroin and swore to God, swore to his own dead daughter, that my dog Purdy ate the money. And this is his latest plan to get clean, coaching a bunch of 10, 11, and 12-year-olds, rounded up by the DC Department of Recreation. All I can say is, "That's great."
鲍比把燃烧的香烟弹到街上，看着我，等待更多反应。这是同一个我爱过并试图拯救了一整年的鲍比，鲍比从我家偷了60美元去买海洛因，并向上帝发誓，向他自己死去的女儿发誓，是我的狗珀迪吃了那笔钱。这是他想要戒毒的最新计划，指导一群由特区娱乐部召集的10、11和12岁孩子。我只能说，“太好了。”
A week later, Bobby's back, this time on my machine.
一周后，鲍比又回来了，这次是在我的答录机上。
You have two messages. Message one.
你有两条留言。第一条留言。
Hey, how are you doing? Just calling to say hi. When I get off, I'll probably walk Bailey. Maybe we'll run up and see if we can say hi to you. Katie, you've got to see this. These thugs I got are unbelievable. One of them tried to spit on me yesterday at practice. A couple of them, I don't think even I can handle. It's like they're too much of a disruption, you know?
嘿，你好吗？只是打电话打个招呼。我下班后可能会去遛贝利。也许我们会跑过去看看能不能跟你打声招呼。凯蒂，你一定要看看这个。我这帮小混混真是不可思议。昨天练习时，其中一个居然试图向我吐口水。他们中有几个人，我觉得连我都应付不了。这就像他们太扰乱秩序了，你知道吗？
[BEEP]
[蜂鸣声]
My machine cuts him off. But now I know Bobby's clean because if he were still using heroin, nothing could puncture his detached haze. He's sounding awake and rattled.
我的答录机截断了他。但现在我知道鲍比戒毒了，因为如果他还在用海洛因，没什么能穿透他那淡漠的迷雾。他听起来清醒且紧张。
Bobby, who spent two and 1/2 years in Lorton prison on assault and possession charges, rattled by a bunch of kids at their first baseball practice.
鲍比，因袭击和非法持有毒品指控在洛顿监狱待了两年半，却被一群在第一次棒球练习中的孩子搞得紧张不安。
The first day, he was just crazy.
第一天，他简直疯了。
We went to Harrison playground at between 13th and 14th on V street. And that's a rough neighborhood.
我们去了V街13街和14街之间的哈里森游乐场。那是一个粗暴的社区。
And as soon as we got on the field, my kids started to act up right away, right away. And I think they were afraid. I was a little afraid.
我们一到球场，我的孩子们就开始胡闹，立刻就开始。我想他们很害怕。我也有一点点害怕。
OK, he was picking who was going to be right field or whatever. But then, everybody was just yelling at each other and jonesing on each other.
好的，他当时在选谁去右外野什么的。但后来，每个人都在互相叫喊，互相嘲讽。
I was trying to get them to chill and relax and play ball, focus on the game. They started cursing me-- a few of them-- cursing me and cursing each other. One kid spit at me.
我试图让他们冷静下来，放松心情，好好打球，专注于比赛。他们开始骂我——几个孩子——骂我和骂对方。有个孩子甚至朝我吐口水。
And he got mad and said practice was over.
然后他生气了，说练习结束了。
And I cursed them and I told them they didn't [BLEEP] impress me. Before they were born, I was in penitentiary. So if they're trying to act like they're bad, they're not impressing me.
我骂了他们，告诉他们他们没能[脏话]打动我。在他们出生之前，我就在监狱里待过了。所以如果他们想表现得自己很坏，他们没能打动我。
And right when I did that, I felt in my gut that I had just screwed up. I felt right then that, you know what? You just laid all of your cards on the table. You don't have a hole card anymore. Now they know you.
就在我做这件事的时候，我直觉地感到我搞砸了。我立刻感到，你知道吗？你刚才把所有的底牌都摊在桌上了。你再也没有底牌了。现在他们了解你了。
Then Shannon said, maybe he got pumped in the butt by lots of men. And that's why everybody was laughing.
然后香农说，也许他被很多男人爆过菊。这就是为什么大家都笑的原因。
One kid says, "Well, while you were in prison, were you getting humped?" And then I knew I screwed up. I said, "No, that didn't happen to me." Another one said, "Oh, because you were the humper, right?"
有个孩子说：“好吧，你在监狱里的时候，是不是被骑了？”然后我就知道我搞砸了。我说：“不，那没发生在我身上。”另一个人说：“哦，因为你是那个骑人的人，对吧？”
Three days later, they hold a second practice, this time at a field in our neighborhood. Bobby's back for more salvation through Little League.
三天后，他们举行了第二次练习，这次是在我们社区的一个球场。鲍比回来寻求通过少棒联盟获得救赎。
Shut up before I smack the shit out you.
闭嘴，不然我扇死你。
Do it.
有本事就做。
What's your strategy? Or maybe you're formulating.
你的策略是什么？或者也许你正在构思。
I'm formulating it. But my strategy, short-term, is to-- my strategy is to remember I'm the adult.
我正在构思。但我的短期策略是——我的策略是记住我是个成年人。
Good stick, go, go, go, go, go. Run it out. He might fall. He might break his ankle. All right. Good stick, good hustle. Hey, every first baseman don't play as good as him.
好球，跑，跑，跑，跑。跑出去。他可能会摔倒。他可能会扭断脚踝。好了。好棒，好努力。嘿，不是每个一垒手都玩得像他那么好。
This second practice is going a lot better. The only tantrums being thrown are by the kids. Bobby stands by the backstop in our park, pushing away a locust sapling that's grown up through the fence.
这第二次练习好多了。唯一发脾气的是孩子们。鲍比站在我们公园的拦网旁，推开一棵从围栏里长出来的刺槐树苗。
There are no bases and only a warped piece of rubber for the pitcher's mound. That's how it goes around here. Anyone with any money drives their kids to the wealthier neighborhoods to play, leaving this misshapen field for Bobby's team.
没有垒包，投手丘上只有一块变形的橡胶片。这就是这里的情况。任何有钱的人都会开车把孩子带到更富裕的社区去玩，把这块变形的球场留给鲍比的球队。
Come on, man. I'm not going to tell you where it's going, but I want you to bring it home when it comes to you. Wake up. Wake up.
来吧，伙计。我不打算告诉你它会去哪，但我希望当它到你手里时，你能把它带回家。醒醒。醒醒。
I thought you were talking about--
我以为你在说——
That's what I'm saying, see? The guy in the game, the batter's not going to tell you where the ball's going, guys.
这就是我所说的，看到没？比赛中的家伙，击球手不会告诉你们球会往哪儿跑的，伙计们。
Talent level-- Bad News Bears. They're horrible, as far as talent. I think they're wonderful kids, and I'm not going to give up on them. But God, man, they can't throw a ball, they can't catch a ball, they can't hit a ball, and they've never learned. No one's ever taught them.
天赋水平——《少棒闯天下》。就天赋而言，他们简直糟透了。我认为他们是了不起的孩子，我不会放弃他们。但天哪，伙计，他们不会投球，不会接球，不会击球，而且他们从未学过。从来没人教过他们。
Bring it home.
带它回家。
[BAT PINGS]
[球棒击球声]
Oh, OK. You've got-- good stop, good throw. That's the way to play, fellas. That's the way to play. Think it's coming your way?
哦，好的。你有——好停，好投。这就是比赛的方式，小伙子们。这就是比赛的方式。觉得球要往你这边来了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah? Heads up.
是吗？注意。
The third practice starts around 5 o'clock on a humid April afternoon. Kids are scattered around the field, squatting down, twirling their gloves. Joey is throwing rocks at his brother. Joey is always throwing rocks. Benjamin thinks he should be pitching. Bobby tells him to stay right where he is and keep catching.
第三次练习在潮湿的四月下午5点左右开始。孩子们散布在球场周围，蹲着，转动着手套。乔伊在向他哥哥扔石头。乔伊总是在扔石头。本杰明认为他应该去当投手。鲍比告诉他就在原地待着继续接球。
That's what I'm talking about right there. Come on, Benjamin.
那就是我在说的，在那儿。来吧，本杰明。
Come on, now.
来吧，现在。
Get that ball.
拿到那个球。
You know?
你知道吗？
Get in front of that ball.
挡在球前面。
Oh, you didn't know?
哦，你不知道？
Now, I do know. You need to learn. Get in front of that ball. Bring it home.
现在我知道了。你需要学习。挡在球前面。带它回家。
After a half hour, things start to spin out of control. Benjamin, the most volatile of the kids, throws a rock at Joey. Bobby tells him to run a lap. "You must be tripping," says Benjamin.
半小时后，情况开始失控。本杰明，这些孩子中最反复无常的一个，向乔伊扔了一块石头。鲍比告诉他跑一圈。“你一定是磕了药，”本杰明说。
"I might be tripping, but you need to be lapping," says Bobby.
“我可能是磕了药，但你需要去跑圈，”鲍比说。
He's going to make me run a lap. And I didn't even throw nothing.
他要让我跑一圈。而且我什么都没扔。
Maybe you need exercise.
也许你需要运动。
Benjamin, he's my favorite because I just see me, more so than any other child on that team. I don't know what his home life is like. But from what I can see, he's emotional. And when he feels cheated or done wrong, he reacts exactly like I always reacted-- violently, verbally with the violence. And he just goes off, [BLEEP] you and [BLEEP] the team.
本杰明是我最喜欢的，因为我看到了我自己，比队里任何其他孩子都多。我不知道他的家庭生活是什么样的。但从我所能看到的，他很情绪化。当他感到受骗或受到不公对待时，他的反应和我一直以来的反应完全一样——暴力，言语上的暴力。他就会爆发，“[脏话]你和[脏话]这个球队。”
And well, that's me. That was me, and in ways, it still is. When I get my feelings hurt, I don't always say, "Well, you really hurt my feelings." I say, "[BLEEP] you, mother-[BLEEP]."
好吧，那是我。那曾经是我，在某种程度上，现在仍然是。当我的感情受到伤害时，我并不总是说，“哦，你真的伤了我的心。”我说，“[脏话]你，你这个[脏话]。”
And you know what I do? What I've done for a lot of years is I would hurt myself because someone hurt me. Well, Benjamin does that at practice.
你知道我做了什么吗？很多年来我一直在做的事就是，有人伤害了我，我就伤害自己。好吧，本杰明在练习时就是这么做的。
No, man, he's always getting on somebody's nerves. [BLEEP] Getting on everybody's nerves.
不，伙计，他总是让人心烦。[脏话]让每个人都心烦。
Bobby finally asked Benjamin to go home and come back next practice. Instead, Benjamin stands over my microphone and starts calling the game as he sees it.
鲍比最后要求本杰明回家，下一次练习再来。相反，本杰明站在我的麦克风前，开始播报他眼中的比赛。
He thinks he's right all the time.
他以为他总是对的。
Who are you talking about?
你在说谁？
The coach. He always-- he press, "Oh, I've been in the penitentiary. I know all this stuff." Man, bump all that, man.
教练。他总是——他强调，“哦，我在监狱里待过。我知道所有这些东西。”伙计，去你的吧，伙计。
Bobby pauses as Benjamin mimics him, then throws the ball up and cracks it to the outfield.
鲍比停顿了一下，本杰明模仿他，然后把球扔起来，用力打向外野。
Bring it home, fellas. Bring it home.
带它回家，伙计们。带它回家。
[BAT PINGS]
[球棒击球声]
A few minutes later, Benjamin finally does a lap, but he walks it.
几分钟后，本杰明终于跑了一圈，但他走完了。
Watch the hop. You still got him. Good throw now, Monty. Thank you. Thank you.
注意那个弹跳。你还是抓住了他。好球，蒙蒂。谢谢。谢谢。
When he was these kids' ages, Bobby ran wild at night, taking money, stealing bikes. Most kids were afraid of him, but he never messed with me and my brothers. I even remember Bobby and his sister eating with us a couple of times because his mom never made dinner.
当他还是这些孩子这个年纪时，鲍比晚上在外面疯跑，拿钱，偷自行车。大多数孩子都怕他，但他从不招惹我和我哥哥。我还记得鲍比和他妹妹跟我们一起吃过几次饭，因为他妈妈从不做晚饭。
When Bobby was 13, his mother caught him stealing change out of her purse and kicked him out of the house. The only place Bobby knew to go was right here to this field, where he now coaches baseball.
鲍比13岁时，他妈妈发现他在偷钱包里的零钱，就把他赶出了家门。鲍比唯一知道去的地方就是这里，这个他现在指导棒球的球场。
You got one more shot at it.
你还有最后一次机会。
It used to be an abandoned lot full of old cars and refrigerators. Here in the left outfield-- where Joey's pacing and muttering because Bobby told him to quit looking for a fight-- right here, there used to be a white '69 Ford Falcon. That's where Bobby went when his mother threw him out.
它曾经是一片堆满旧车和冰箱的废弃空地。就在左外野——乔伊在那儿踱步嘀咕，因为鲍比告诉他别再找茬了——就在这儿，曾经有一辆白色的69年福特猎鹰。那就是鲍比妈妈把他赶出来后去的地方。
I spray painted all the windows black so no one could see in, and I would shoplift food from the corner store, Matty's Delicatessen, neighborhood deli-- stuff like Vienna sausages and a bottle of wine and go to sleep with at night and sardines. And that was dinner.
我把所有的窗户都喷成了黑色，这样就没人能看见里面，我会从街角的店里偷食物，马蒂熟食店，邻里的熟食店——比如维也纳香肠和一瓶葡萄酒，晚上就在那睡觉，还有沙丁鱼。那就是晚餐。
Bobby says that alcohol helped him feel less afraid late at night in that old Ford. Soon, he found pot, then PCP. In his 20s, he started shooting heroin.
鲍比说，酒精帮助他在深夜里在那辆旧福特车里感到不那么害怕。很快，他发现了大麻，然后是PCP。20多岁时，他开始注射海洛因。
Sorry, that little big-headed little kid, like a whole bunch of little leprechauns running around.
抱歉，那个大头的小屁孩，就像一大群小妖精跑来跑去。
Trash is talked at every practice, and Bobby is teased relentlessly for wearing Payless shoes, which the kids would never be caught dead in. Brandon, the eight-year-old, calls Bobby powdered doughnut because he's white. And he likes to lean into Bobby and whisper, "Punk."
每次练习都有人在说垃圾话，鲍比因为穿着Payless的鞋子而受到无情的嘲笑，孩子们才不会穿那种鞋子。布兰登，那个八岁的孩子，管鲍比叫粉红甜甜圈，因为他是白人。他喜欢凑近鲍比耳边低语，“朋克。”
Mostly, Bobby laughs. Other times, though, especially when the kids start in on each other, it can get to him.
大多时候，鲍比会笑。但有时候，尤其是当孩子们开始互相攻击时，这会影响到他。
Fellas, fellas, I can't talk if you're talking.
小伙子们，小伙子们，如果你们都在说话，我就没法说了。
Coach, you need some more gloves, man.
教练，你需要更多手套，伙计。
I'm about ready to put the gloves in the bag and go home. Give me this stuff. Let me roll.
我准备把手套放进袋子里回家了。给我那些东西。让我走吧。
You can do that, Coach. It's fine.
你可以那么做，教练。没关系。
No, man. No, man.
不，伙计。不，伙计。
I'm serious, boys. Shut up. Everybody shut up, please.
我是认真的，孩子们。闭嘴。每个人都闭嘴，求你们了。
Bobby picks up the bat bag and slams it against a brick wall.
鲍比拿起球棒袋，狠狠地撞向砖墙。
Chill, OK? Chill. I can't talk if you're all talking. OK, look here. I'm sorry--
冷静，好吗？冷静。如果你们都在说话，我就没法说了。好的，看着这儿。我很抱歉——
What's up, fellas? What's happening?
怎么了，小伙子们？发生了什么事？
Somewhere around the third or fourth practice, without announcing it in any way, the boys start calling Bobby "Coach." "Coach, can you fix this glove? Coach, which bat should I use?"
大约在第三或第四次练习时，孩子们开始叫鲍比“教练”，没有任何预兆。“教练，你能修修这手套吗？教练，我该用哪根球棒？”
What's it like when the kids call you Coach?
当孩子们叫你教练时，是什么感觉？
You know, it didn't really hit me at first, you know? I took them to a picnic a couple of weekends ago that some recovering alcoholic and addict friends of mine threw. And to hear people there-- "hey, Bobby, hey, Bobby"-- and then to hear this group of kids that I came with-- "hey, Coach, hey, Coach"-- that's when it sort of hit me that, hey, man, that's just who you are.
你知道，一开始这并没有真正打动我，你知道吗？几个周末前，我带他们参加了一个由我一些正在戒酒和戒毒的朋友举办的野餐。听到那里的人说——“嘿，鲍比，嘿，鲍比”——然后听到我带来的这群孩子说——“嘿，教练，嘿，教练”——就在那时，我突然意识到，嘿，伙计，你就是这样的人。
And these people now see me as Coach, not just Bobby the recovering dope fiend, you know? He's Coach. So that makes me feel good to have these kids call me Coach.
这些人现在把我当成教练，而不仅仅是那个戒毒的鲍比，你知道吗？他是教练。所以让这些孩子叫我教练让我感觉很好。
So I don't know. Now I have this little small part in shaping what their day is going to be like, you know?
所以我不知道。现在我在塑造他们的一天会是什么样这件事上，有了一点点小的作用，你知道吗？
When he told me that he had come from prison and he got shot in his neck, I thought he was just another one of them people who like to talk about their life and then get over it. But I learned to understand him.
当他告诉我他来自监狱，脖子还中过枪时，我还以为他只是那种喜欢谈论自己生活然后翻篇的人。但我学会了理解他。
How do you understand him?
你怎么理解他？
He don't want no trouble. He just wants us to listen to him. But I guess as you grow into people, you start to have more patience.
他不想要麻烦。他只是想让我们听他的话。但我猜随着你与人相处，你会开始有更多的耐心。
As you roll into people?
随着你与人相处？
Grow. You start to have more patience. And I think that's what's happening.
成长。你开始有更多的耐心。我认为这就是正在发生的事情。
The Department of Recreation gives Bobby an ID badge, which he wears around his neck when he comes down to the neighborhood, like a sign-- I am no longer a dope fiend. I'm doing something good. Most people might keep it in their pocket. Bobby wears it right on his chest.
娱乐部给了鲍比一个身份证件，当他来到社区时，他把它挂在脖子上，就像一个标志——我不再是一个瘾君子了。我在做一件好事。大多数人可能会把它放在口袋里。鲍比把它戴在胸前。
I just walk around with my head high and feeling proud, for the most part, very proud of what I'm doing.
我只是昂着头走来走去，感觉很骄傲，在很大程度上，对我所做的事情感到非常骄傲。
The skeptics are everywhere, though-- neighbors who gave him advances for paint jobs he never did, people he stole bank cards from, people he actually spit on.
然而怀疑论者无处不在——邻居们给了他还没完成的刷漆工作的预付款，他从那儿偷过银行卡的人，他甚至向那儿吐过口水的人。
What is that like for you to walk around in the neighborhood, and you might even walk by somebody that you owe money to or conned money out of?
在社区里走来走去，甚至可能走过你欠钱的人或骗过钱的人，那对你来说是什么感觉？
It's hard to explain, really. It's a roller coaster of emotions. There's times-- and right when I'm feeling like the world is wonderful, when everything is going my way, I'll see someone that I had conned out of a few hundred bucks. And the voice in my head will immediately say, "See there? You're still a scumbag. Remember when-- look, that's who you really are."
这真的很难解释。这是一种情绪过山车。有那么几次——就在我感觉世界很美好，一切都很顺利的时候，我会看到一个我骗了几百美元的人。我脑子里的声音会立刻说，“看那儿？你还是个人渣。记得当时——看，那才是真正的你。”
So what do you do when you see that person?
那你看到那个人时会怎么做？
It depends. It depends on how I feel. And there's times when I might be feeling real insecure and I'll put that macho thing up. And I'll put the cocky thing up and hope they say something wrong to me so that I can go south with them, you know?
这取决于情况。取决于我的感受。有时候我可能会感觉非常不安全，我会表现出那种男子气概。我会摆出那种傲慢的样子，希望他们对我大吼大叫，这样我就可以和他们一起下沉，你知道吗？
Do you do that?
你这么做了吗？
No, but I want to. I want to. I mean, there's a part of me that still wants to be a thug. There's a part of me still very capable of being a thug. I just wouldn't be able to be a real good thug with my hands because I'm older. I'd have to get a weapon now.
没有，但我很想。我很想。我的意思是，我内心的一部分仍然想成为一个混混。我内心的一部分仍然很有潜力成为一个混混。我只是无法用手做一个真正的坏混混，因为我老了。我现在得弄件武器。
I ain't wearing no girly thing.
我才不穿那种娘娘腔的东西。
It's early May. And after 10 practices, the kids are finally stepping into their uniforms at the local recreation center. This is the first new thing they've seen all season. Their bats and gloves are splintered and old. But the uniforms are bright blue and gray, Texas Ranger uniforms with red caps.
五月初了。经过10次练习，孩子们终于在当地的娱乐中心穿上了制服。这是他们整个赛季见过的第一件新东西。他们的球棒和手套已经开裂且陈旧了。但制服是明亮的蓝色和灰色，德州游骑兵队的制服，配着红色帽子。
Bobby is tanned and relaxed, dancing around, faking jabs, counting the kids to see if he can field a team-- never a sure thing. Today, they're exactly nine boys, the day of their first game against another team.
鲍比晒黑了，很放松，跳来跳去，假装出拳，数着孩子看能不能凑齐一支球队——这从来不是件确定的事。今天，他们正好是9个男孩，他们对阵另一支球队的第一场比赛的日子。
The recreation bus is an hour late to take the team to their game, so some of us go on a taxi, six kids and I all squished together. Bobby and the others are hailing a cab when the bus finally shows up. We all pile out at what is supposedly the best Little League field in the city. The grass is shin-high. There's a pile of dirt in the outfield. No fans, no parents-- just Bobby and the team.
娱乐部的巴士晚点了一个小时去接球队去比赛，所以我们几个搭出租车，六个孩子和我挤在一起。当巴士终于出现时，鲍比和其他人正在叫出租车。我们都下车来到所谓的城里最好的少棒联盟球场。草长到了小腿高。外野有一堆土。没有球迷，没有家长——只有鲍比和球队。
That means I have a feel, I can slap him.
这意味着我有一种感觉，我可以拍他一下。
Hey, what time is it?
嘿，现在几点了？
About 5:06.
大概5点06分。
Dang, man.
该死，伙计。
Oh, the other team forfeited.
哦，对方弃权了。
The other team never shows, so Bobby's team wins by default. Some other kids are in the same boat, so there's an impromptu scrimmage. And official or not, this is the first baseball game that most of these kids have ever played.
对方从没出现，所以鲍比的球队默认获胜。其他一些孩子也处于同样的境地，所以举行了一场即兴比赛。不管正式与否，这是这些孩子中大多数人打过的第一场棒球比赛。
It's too damn small, man. We would tear them up.
这太他妈小了，伙计。我们会撕碎他们的。
Uh-huh, OK, what's up, shut up, uh-huh, OK.
嗯哼，好的，怎么了，闭嘴，嗯哼，好的。
The other team is small but very fast, and they have three coaches who tell them when to steal bases. So a line drive becomes a run, then another run, and another run. And it's 5-0.
对方规模很小但速度很快，他们有三个教练告诉他们什么时候盗垒。所以一个平飞球变成了得分，然后又得一分，又得一分。变成了5比0。
He stole home on y'all.
他盗垒成功，回到本垒。
Good play, good play, Carlos.
好球，好球，卡洛斯。
So we'll see what we need to work on today instead of looking good in our uniforms. Come on, let's get an out. We've got to force to second. Get the force to second.
所以我们来看看今天我们需要练习什么，而不是看起来很帅。来吧，让我们打个出局。我们必须强迫到二垒。强迫到二垒。
The season lurches forward with DC Recreation canceling games for no reason, never rescheduling rainouts. The uniforms are not washed for three weeks. And one day, no one shows up to let the boys in to suit up for a game, so they have to forfeit. By June, Bobby's team has only played one real game-- one game in four months.
赛季艰难前行，DC娱乐部无缘无故取消比赛，从不重新安排雨天补赛。制服三周没洗。有一天，没有人来让孩子们进去换装比赛，所以他们不得不弃权。到六月，鲍比的球队只打了一场真正的比赛——四个月里只打了一场。
In this inconsistent world, Bobby is someone the kids can count on. He never misses practice, coming in his painter's pants most days to hit the ball to them. And while it might seem like Bobby's keeping the kids in line, he'll tell you that's what they're doing for him.
在这个不稳定的世界里，鲍比是孩子们可以依靠的人。他从不缺席练习，大多数时候穿着油漆工裤子来给他们击球。虽然看起来好像是鲍比在约束孩子们，但他会告诉你，正是孩子们在约束他。
I don't want to have to avoid my neighborhood. I don't want to have to avoid my community playground because I let these kids down because I'm a drunken dope fiend [BLEEP] bum, which is what I become if I go have a beer right now or some dope right now. Tomorrow, I'm a bum because all the good feelings are gone.
我不想不得不避开我的社区。我不想不得不避开我的社区游乐场，因为我辜负了这些孩子，因为我是个喝醉的毒鬼[脏话]流浪汉，如果我现在去喝杯啤酒或吸点毒，我就成了那样。明天，我就成了个流浪汉，因为所有美好的感觉都消失了。
I don't want to feel the shame which I felt from relapses. And it's big-time shame. It's shame. I won't be able to look these kids in their eyes, in their faces. I'll duck them. God, I'm 42 years old, and I would have to come to my own neighborhood and duck children because I'm ashamed. I don't want that.
我不想感受复吸带来的羞耻感。那是巨大的羞耻感。它是羞耻。我无法直视这些孩子的眼睛，直视他们的脸。我会躲着他们。上帝，我都42岁了，我竟然得来到我自己的社区躲着孩子们，因为我感到羞耻。我不想要那样。
Throw that smoke. Throw that smoke. Throw that smoke. You're the man out there. You're the man.
投出那道烟雾。投出那道烟雾。投出那道烟雾。你是那里的男人。你是男人。
By June, Bobby's team gets its first win with some great pitching from Donald and a catch by Ricardo in the third inning that looks more like a football interception.
到了六月，鲍比的球队获得了首胜，得益于唐纳德出色的投球和里卡多在第三局的接球，看起来更像橄榄球拦截。
Woo-hoo! Yeah! Oh, man. Boy, that was a major-league catch, man. I don't make catches like that. Woo-hoo!
呜呼！耶！哦，伙计。天哪，那是一个大联盟式的接球，伙计。我可做不出那样的接球。呜呼！
And while they wait for their bus to take them back home, the boys start tussling with each other, rolling around on a grassy hill.
当他们等待巴士带他们回家时，男孩们开始互相打闹，在草地上打滚。
They're celebrating their win.
他们在庆祝胜利。
They are celebrating their win by wrestling. I'm about to myself.
他们在通过摔跤庆祝胜利。我都有点想加入。
This is easily the sweetest moment of the season, not only because of the win, but because it's amazing to see the boys so happy. And this is what Bobby will remember when Justin and Ricardo get in a real fight an hour later, when he has to suspend Benjamin not once, but twice, and when Joey threatens to beat up a kid from another team. Always that delicate balance-- fragile, like sobriety.
这是本赛季最甜蜜的时刻，不仅因为胜利，更因为看到孩子们如此快乐真是太棒了。而这就是鲍比以后会记住的东西，即使Justin和Ricardo一小时后真的打了起来，当他不得不不仅一次而是两次禁赛Benjamin，以及当Joey威胁要打另一个球队的孩子时。永远是那种微妙的平衡——像清醒一样脆弱。
Time out, time out. I got to tie my shoe.
暂停，暂停。我得系鞋带。
I always thought I was going to be a loser forever. First of all, being clean makes me feel like, OK, I've got a chance to be a winner. But the kids, especially-- it's something about kids, you know? This is something I never thought, man, that I'd be able to do.
我一直以为我会永远是个失败者。首先，保持清醒让我觉得，好的，我有机会成为一个赢家。但孩子们，尤其是——关于孩子们有些东西，你知道吗？这是我从没想过的，伙计，我竟然能做到这一点。
When I was walking after a practice, like, a week or two ago, I swear to God, I walked across Duke Ellington Bridge to the subway, and I started crying. I started crying because I was so [BLEEP] happy-- so happy that, damn, this is probably going to work out. I'm probably going to be able to pull this off.
当我练习后走路时，大概是一两周前，我对上帝发誓，我走过杜克·艾林顿大桥去地铁站，我开始哭了。我开始哭，因为我太[脏话]快乐了——太快乐了，该死，这可能会成功。我可能真的能成功。
By the end of the season, the kids have a record of two wins and no losses. Playoffs never get scheduled, so there's no reason to practice anymore. No one knows where Benjamin is these days. And just this week, I saw Joey stealing a soda from the corner store, and I made him take it back.
赛季结束时，孩子们有两胜零负的记录。季后赛从未排上日程，所以没理由再练习了。没人知道Benjamin最近在哪里。就在这周，我看到Joey在小卖部偷汽水，我让他把它送回去。
Bobby still comes around, though, and hangs out in the park, talks with the boys. And he sometimes shoots one-on-one with them. And he says, "Stick with me. I'm going to have tryouts for 12-and-under basketball team. I'm going to still be coming around here."
不过鲍比还是会过来，在公园里闲逛，和孩子们聊天。他有时还跟他们打一对一。他说：“跟我待在一起。我要为12岁以下篮球队举行选拔赛。我会一直来这儿的。”
Oh, you're going to get it now.
哦，你现在要倒霉了。
Katie Davis, in Washington, DC.
凯蒂·戴维斯，在华盛顿特区。
Act Four, What Police Cannot Do. The clues at a crime scene are not always conclusive, of course. Lots of crimes are forever unsolved. People die and it's never explained why. Stuff disappears and is never found again, though we want it to be. We end our program today with this crime scene story from writer Aimee Bender, read for us by Matt Malloy.
第四幕，“警察做不到的事”。当然，犯罪现场的线索并不总是决定性的。很多犯罪永远无法侦破。人们死去，却永远无法解释原因。东西消失了，却永远找不回来，尽管我们希望它们能找回来。我们以这篇来自作家艾米·本德的犯罪现场故事结束我们今天的节目，由马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
Once there was an orphan who had a knack for finding lost things. Both his parents had been killed when he was eight years old. They were swimming in the ocean when it turned wild with waves, and each had tried to save the other from drowning. The boy woke up from a nap on the sand, alone.
曾经有一个孤儿，他有一种寻找丢失东西的天赋。他的父母在他八岁时双双遇难。他们在海里游泳时，海浪变得狂暴，两人都试图从溺水中救出对方。男孩在沙滩上睡午觉醒来，独自一人。
After the tragedy, the community adopted and raised him. And a few years after the death of his parents, he began to have a sense of objects, even when they weren't visible. This ability continued growing in power through his teens. And by his 20s, he was able to actually sniff out lost sunglasses, keys, contact lenses, and sweaters. The neighbors discovered his talent accidentally.
悲剧发生后，社区收养并抚养了他。在他父母去世几年后，他开始对物体产生一种感知，即使它们不可见。这种能力在他的青少年时期不断增强。到了20多岁，他甚至能真正嗅出丢失的太阳镜、钥匙、隐形眼镜和毛衣。邻居们偶然发现了他的天赋。
He was over at Jenny Sugar's house one evening, picking her up for a date, when Jenny's mother misplaced her hairbrush and was walking around complaining about this. The young man's nose twitched, and he turned slightly towards the kitchen and pointed to the drawer where the spoons and knives were kept.
一天晚上，他在珍妮·舒格家接她去约会时，珍妮的妈妈弄丢了发刷，到处抱怨这件事。年轻人的鼻子抽动了一下，他稍微转向厨房，指向放勺子和刀子的抽屉。
His date burst into laughter. "Now, that would be quite a silly place to put the brush," she said, "among all that silverware." And she opened the door to make her point, to wave with a knife or brush her hair with a spoon. But when she did, boom-- there was the hairbrush, matted with gray curls, sitting on top of the pile.
他的约会对象爆发出笑声。“那倒是个把发刷放进那些餐具里的愚蠢地方，”她说。她打开门想证明自己的观点，想挥舞一把刀子或者用勺子刷头发。但当她这样做时，砰——发刷就在那儿，上面粘着灰色的卷发，正坐在那堆东西上面。
Jenny's mother kissed the young man on the cheek, but Jenny herself looked at him suspiciously all night long. "You planned all that, didn't you?" she said over dinner. "You were trying to impress my mother. Well, you didn't impress me," she said.
珍妮的妈妈亲了年轻人的脸颊，但珍妮本人整晚都对他持怀疑态度。“你策划了这一切，对吧？”她在晚餐时说。“你是在试图给我妈妈留下深刻印象。嗯，你没给我留下印象，”她说。
He tried to explain himself, but she would hear none of it. And when he drove his car up to her house, she fled before he could even finish saying he'd had a nice time, which was a lie anyway. He went home to his tiny room and thought about the word "lonely," and how it sounded and looked so lonely, with those two Ls in it, each standing tall by itself.
他试图解释自己，但她根本听不进去。当他开车到她家门口时，她甚至在他说完度过了一段美好时光之前就跑了，那本来就是个谎言。他回到自己狭小的房间，思考着“孤独”这个词，它听起来和看起来是多么孤独，里面那两个L，每个都独自站立着。
As news spread around the neighborhood about the young man's skills, people reacted in two ways. There were the deeply appreciative and the skeptics. The appreciative ones called up the young man regularly. He'd stop by on his way to school, find their keys, and they'd give him a homemade muffin.
随着关于这个年轻人技能的消息在社区传播开来，人们以两种方式做出反应。有深表感激的和怀疑论者。感激的人经常打电话给这个年轻人。他在上学路上顺道过来，找到他们的钥匙，他们会给他一个自制的松饼。
The skeptics called him over, too, and watched him like a hawk. He'd still find their lost items, but they'd insist it was an elaborate scam and he was doing it all to get attention.
怀疑论者也把他叫过去，像老鹰一样盯着他。他仍然能找到他们丢失的物品，但他们会坚称这是一个精心策划的骗局，他做这一切只是为了引起注意。
"Maybe," declared one woman, waving her index finger in the air, "maybe," she said, "he steals the thing so we think it's lost, moves the item, and then comes over to save it. How do we know it was really lost in the first place? What is going on?"
“也许，”一位女士宣布，将食指指向空中，“也许，”她说，“也许是他偷了东西，让我们以为它丢了，移动了物品，然后跑过来挽救它。我们怎么知道它一开始就真的丢了呢？这到底是怎么回事？”
The young man didn't know, himself. All he knew was the feeling of a tug-- light but insistent-- like a child at his sleeve. And that tug would turn him in the right direction and show him where to look. Each object had its own way of inhabiting space, and therefore, messaging its location. The young man could sense, could smell an object's presence. He did not need to see it to feel where it put its gravity down. As would be expected, items that turned out to be miles away took much harder concentration than the ones that were two feet to the left.
年轻人自己也不知道。他所知道的只是那种被拉扯的感觉——轻微但坚持——就像一个孩子拽着他的袖子。那种拉扯会让他转向正确的方向，并告诉他去哪里寻找。每个物体都有其自身占据空间的方式，因此，也就传达了其位置。年轻人能感知，能嗅到物体的存在。他不需要看到它就能感觉到它在哪里放下重心。正如预料的那样，最终发现离得很远的物品比两英尺左边的那些需要更集中的注意力。
When Mrs. Allen's little boy didn't come home one afternoon, that was the most difficult of all. Leonard Allen was eight years old and usually arrived home from school at 3:05. He had allergies and needed a pill before he went back out to play.
当艾伦太太的小男孩一天下午没回家时，那是最困难的。伦纳德·艾伦八岁，通常下午3点05分放学回家。他有过敏症，在再次出去玩之前需要吃一粒药。
That day by 3:45, alone, Mrs. Allen was a wreck. Her boy rarely got lost. Only once had that happened in the supermarket, but he'd been found quite easily under the produce tables, crying. The walk home from school was a straight line, and Leonard was not the wandering kind.
那天到了3点45分，独自一人的艾伦太太崩溃了。她的孩子很少走丢。只有一次发生过这种事，是在超市里，但他被轻易地在农产品桌下找到了，正在哭泣。从学校回家的路是一条直线，伦纳德不是那种会溜达的孩子。
Mrs. Allen was just a regular neighbor, except for one extraordinary fact. Through an inheritance, she was the owner of a gargantuan emerald she called the Green Star. It sat glass-cased in her kitchen where everyone could see it, because she insisted that it be seen. Sometimes, as a party trick, she'd even cut steak with its beveled edge.
艾伦太太只是一个普通的邻居，除了一个非凡的事实。通过遗产，她拥有一颗巨大的祖母绿，她称之为“绿色之星”。它被玻璃罩在厨房里，每个人都能看到，因为她坚持要让它被看到。有时，作为派对把戏，她甚至用它斜面边缘切牛排。
On this day, she took the Green Star out of its case and stuck her palms on it. "Where is my boy?" she cried. The Green Star was cold and flat. She ran weeping to her neighbor, who calmly walked her back home. Together, they gave the house a thorough search, and then the neighbor, a believer, recommended calling the young man.
这一天，她从柜子里拿出“绿色之星”，双手紧紧抓住它。“我的孩子在哪里？”她哭喊道。“绿色之星”冰冷而扁平。她哭着跑去找她的邻居，邻居冷静地陪她走回家。他们一起对房子进行了彻底搜索，然后邻居，一个信仰者，建议打电话给那个年轻人。
Although Mrs. Allen was a skeptic, she thought anything was a worthwhile idea. And when the phone answered, she said in a trembling voice, "You must find my boy."
虽然艾伦太太是个怀疑论者，但她认为任何办法都值得一试。当电话接通时，她颤抖着声音说：“你必须找到我的孩子。”
The young man had been just about to go play basketball with his friends. He'd located the basketball in the bathtub. "You lost him?" said the young man.
年轻人正要和朋友们去打篮球。他刚才在浴缸里找到了篮球。“你把他弄丢了？”年轻人说。
Mrs. Allen began to explain, and then her phone clicked. "One moment, please," she said. And the young man held on.
艾伦太太开始解释，然后她的电话咔哒一声。“请稍等，”她说。年轻人等在电话旁。
When her voice returned, it was shaking with rage. "He's been kidnapped," she said. "They want the Green Star."
当她的声音恢复时，正因为愤怒而颤抖。“他被绑架了，”她说。“他们想要那颗‘绿色之星’。”
The young man realized then that it was Mrs. Allen he was talking to and nodded. "Oh," he said, "I see."
年轻人这时意识到他正在和艾伦太太通话，点了点头。“哦，”他说，“我明白了。”
Everyone in town was familiar with Mrs. Allen's Green Star. "I'll be right over," he said. The woman's voice was too run with tears to respond.
镇上的每个人都知道艾伦太太的那颗“绿色之星”。“我马上过来，”他说。那个女人的声音太被泪水淹没了，无法回应。
In his basketball shorts and shirt, the young man jogged over to Mrs. Allen's house. He was amazed at how the Green Star was all exactly the same shade of green. He had a desire to lick it.
穿着篮球短裤和衬衫，年轻人慢跑向艾伦太太的房子。他很惊叹“绿色之星”的每一处竟是完全相同的绿色。他有一种想舔它的冲动。
By then, Mrs. Allen was in hysterics. "They didn't tell me what to do," she sobbed. "Where do I bring my emerald? How do I get my boy back?"
那时，艾伦太太已经歇斯底里了。“他们没告诉我该怎么办，”她抽泣道。“我把我的祖母绿带到哪里去？我怎么才能把孩子找回来？”
The young man tried to feel the scent of the boy. He asked for a photograph and stared at it, a brown-haired kid at his kindergarten graduation. But the young man had only found objects before, and lost objects at that. He'd never found anything or anybody stolen. He wasn't a policeman.
年轻人试图感受孩子的味道。他要了一张照片盯着看，一个棕色头发的孩子在他幼儿园毕业典礼上。但年轻人以前只找过物体，而且是丢失的物体。他从未找过任何被偷的东西或人。他不是警察。
Mrs. Allen called the police, and one officer showed up at the door. "Oh, it's the finding guy," the officer said. The young man dipped his head modestly. He turned to his right, to his left, north, south. He got a glimmer of a feeling towards the north and walked out the back door through the backyard. Night approached, and the sky seemed to grow and deepen in the darkness.
艾伦太太报了警，一名警官出现在门口。“哦，是那个找东西的家伙，”警官说。年轻人谦虚地低下了头。他转向右边，左边，北边，南边。他感觉到北方有一种微弱的感觉，于是走出后门穿过后院。夜晚临近，天空在黑暗中似乎在扩张和加深。
"What's his name again?" he called back to Mrs. Allen.
“他叫什么名字来着？”他向艾伦太太喊道。
"Leonard," she said.
“伦纳德，”她说。
He heard the policeman pull out a pad and begin to ask basic questions. He couldn't quite feel him. He felt the air, and he felt the tug inside the Green Star, an object displaced from its original home in Asia. He felt the tug of a tree in the front yard, which had been uprooted from Virginia to be replanted here.
他听到警察拿出本子开始问基本问题。他无法准确感知他。他感觉到了空气，他感觉到了“绿色之星”里面的那种拉扯，一个从亚洲原产地移位的物体。他感觉到了前院一棵树的拉扯，它是从弗吉尼亚被连根拔起并重新栽种在这里的。
And he felt the tug of his own watch, which was from his uncle. In an attempt to be fatherly, his uncle had insisted he take it, but they both knew the gesture was false. Maybe the boy was too far away by now.
他感觉到了自己手表的拉扯，那是他叔叔给的。为了显得有父爱，他叔叔坚持让他戴上，但他们俩都知道这个姿态是虚假的。也许孩子现在离得太远了。
He heard the policeman ask, "What is he wearing?"
他听到警官问：“他穿什么衣服？”
Mrs. Allen described a blue shirt, and the young man focused in on the blue shirt. He turned off his distractions, and the blue shirt came calling from the northwest, like a distant radio station. The young man went walking and walking. And about 14 houses down, he felt the blue shirt shrieking at him.
艾伦太太描述了一件蓝色衬衫，年轻人把注意力集中在那件蓝色衬衫上。他关掉了干扰，蓝色衬衫从西北方向传来呼唤，就像一个遥远的广播电台。年轻人走着，一直走着。大约14栋房子之外，他感觉到了那件蓝色衬衫在向他尖叫。
And he walked right into the backyard, right through the back door. And sure enough, there were four people watching TV, including the tear-stained boy with a runny nose eating a candy bar. The young man scooped up the boy while the others watched, so surprised they did nothing. And one even muttered, "Sorry, man."
他直接走进后院，直接穿过后门。果不其然，有四个人在看电视，包括那个满脸泪痕、流着鼻涕、正在吃糖果条的男孩。年轻人抱起男孩，其他人看着，非常惊讶，什么都没做。甚至有一个人喃喃道：“对不起，伙计。”
For 14 houses back, the young man held Leonard in his arms like a bride. Leonard stopped sneezing and looked up at the stars. And the young man smelled Leonard's hair, rich with the memory of peanut butter. He hoped Leonard would ask him a question, any question. But Leonard was quiet.
抱着他穿回14栋房子，年轻人像抱新娘一样把伦纳德抱在怀里。伦纳德停止打喷嚏，抬头看着星星。年轻人闻着伦纳德头发的味道，那是浓郁的花生酱记忆。他希望伦纳德能问他一个问题，任何问题。但伦纳德很安静。
The young man answered in his head. "Son," he said to himself. And the word rolled around the marble, on a marble floor. "Son," he wanted to say.
年轻人在脑海中回答。“儿子，”他对自己说。这个词在大理石地板上的弹珠上滚动。“儿子，”他想说。
When he reached Mrs. Allen's door, which was wide open, he walked in with quiet Leonard, and Mrs. Allen promptly burst into tears. And the policeman slunked out the door. She thanked the young man a thousand times, even offered him the Green Star, but he refused it.
当他到达艾伦太太那扇敞开的门时，他带着安静的伦纳德走进去，艾伦太太立刻泪如雨下。警察悄悄溜出了门。她千次万次地感谢那个年轻人，甚至要把“绿色之星”给他，但他拒绝了。
Leonard turned on the TV and curled up on the sofa. The young man walked over and asked him about the program he was watching, but Leonard stuck his thumb in his mouth and didn't respond. "Feel better," he said softly.
伦纳德打开电视，蜷缩在沙发上。年轻人走过去问他正在看什么节目，但伦纳德把拇指放进嘴里没有回应。“感觉好点了吗，”他轻声说。
Tucking the basketball beneath his arm, the young man walked home, shoulders low. In his tiny room, he undressed and lay in bed. Had it been a naked child with nothing on-- no shoes, no necklace, no hair bow, no watch-- he could not have found it.
把篮球夹在腋下，年轻人低着肩膀走回家。在他狭小的房间里，他脱下衣服躺在床上。如果那是一个一丝不挂的孩子——没有鞋，没有项链，没有发饰，没有手表——他是不可能找到他的。
He lay in bed that night with the trees from other places rustling, and he could feel their confusion. No snow here, not a lot of rain-- where am I? What is wrong with this dirt?
那天晚上他躺在床上，来自其他地方的树木沙沙作响，他能感觉到它们的困惑。这里没有雪，雨水也不多——我在哪里？这泥土怎么了？
Crossing his hands in front of him, he held on to his shoulders. Concentrate hard, he thought. Where are you? Everything felt blank and quiet. He couldn't feel a tug.
双手交叉在胸前，他抓住了自己的肩膀。努力集中精神，他想。你在哪里？一切都感到空白和安静。他感觉不到拉扯。
He squeezed his eyes shut and let the question bubble up. Where did you go? Come find me. I'm over here. Come find me. If he listened hard enough, he thought he could hear the waves hitting.
他紧紧闭上眼睛，让这个问题冒出来。你去哪儿了？快来找我。我就在这儿。快来找我。如果他听得足够仔细，他想他能听到海浪拍打的声音。
Aimee Bender's short story is called "Loser." It's from her collection of short fiction called The Girl in the Flammable Skirt. It was read for us by Matt Malloy.
艾米·本德的短篇小说叫“失败者”。它来自她的短篇小说集《穿着易燃裙子的女孩》。由马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Mary Wiltenburg. Marketing help from Marijus Drousceau and the folks at PRI.
好了，我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我制作，苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德参与。特约编辑保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼和玛丽·威尔滕堡提供制作协助。玛丽尤斯·德鲁索和国际公共广播电台的伙伴提供营销帮助。
Special thanks today to Marion Roach, Cheryl Miller, Bob Cargee, Robert Kershner, and John O'Leary.
今天特别感谢玛丽恩·罗奇、谢丽尔·米勒、鲍勃·卡吉、罗伯特·克什纳和约翰·奥利里。
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org.
购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电我们芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。
Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. Thanks to Joanne, Rob, and Dale of the Cola Mail system for hosting our weekly email news update. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
感谢伊丽莎白·迈斯特，她负责运营该网站。感谢Cola邮件系统的乔安、罗伯和戴尔主持我们的每周电子邮件新闻更新。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
Funding for our show has been provided by Amazon.com, helping you find your next favorite book with over 13 million titles online at Amazon.com. Other funding comes from the Capital Group companies, investing for individuals and institutions throughout the world and sponsor of the American Funds group of mutual funds, and from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, the National Endowment for the Arts, the Albert A. List Foundation, and the listeners of WBEZ Chicago.
我们节目的资金由Amazon.com提供，帮助你在Amazon.com上在线找到超过1300万种书目中的下一本最爱。其他资金来自Capital Group公司，为全球个人和机构投资，也是美国基金系列共同基金的赞助商；以及来自公共广播公司、国家艺术基金会、阿尔伯特·A·利斯特基金会和芝加哥WBEZ的听众。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. And who does Torey believe when it comes to climate change and global warming?
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。托里在气候变化和全球变暖问题上相信谁呢？
About a 10-by-5-foot square pool of just gore.
大约一片10乘5英尺的血浆池。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。